welcome back everybody it's time for
another LED live and we are gonna talk
about the topic of time do you guys
waste a lot of time or you spending your
time wisely find out on this episode of
LED live all right guys we're back at it
here's the topic of time does it seem
like we're always out of time you know
like like the little rabbit from whatsit
what's the question
Alice in Wonderland races running around
he's all eyes at a time yeah I feel like
a chicken running around with my head
cut off a lot of time right yes yes but
time is an issue that I think we all
need to be aware of but before we get
into that we want to thank all of our
patreon donors it's time to give you
guys prompts for all the support and
love that you've shared with us that
allows us to even be able to do this so
thank you guys for supporting us on
patreon and we want you to know that if
you haven't signed up for it to be a
patreon donor you know we have a lot of
things that we try to put out extra
content there perks that only are
specifically for our patreon donors so
if you guys would like to see a little
bit more maybe some behind the scenes
check us out we also want to tell you we
sell t-shirts if you're new to our
channel you probably hear us say this
every single time but we're always
wearing t-shirts on all of our shows and
we've got a lot of cool designs so check
on the links below and hit us up with
some t-shirts because that also helps
support our ministry in many different
ways and today we want to highlight a
couple of videos documentaries that we
have made over the years one called sued
ology that really talks about the brain
and and what happens in the brain when
we watch TV or movies very interesting
because when you kind of understand how
the mechanics
of it works and we waste a lot of time
watching movies and television this is a
great documentary for you if you haven't
seen it already also a lot of people
waste a lot of time and social media so
we want to share with you a documentary
that we made called hashtag selfie and
really kind of goes over the use of
social media and the time that everybody
spends and also if we think of media and
the way people waste a lot of time video
games right we've covered that topic
many times on this channel and that
we've got lots of documentaries so check
them out they're called controllers one
two three and those are got some videos
that will give you some great
information
on the video game topic we also have
some other documentaries called the
replacement gods if you're into
superheroes which a lot of people are
these days you might want to be aware of
some of the messages that are in there
where some of these superheroes come
from so we've made two documentaries on
this replacement God's wanted to check
them out they're awesome and if you
don't like DVDs don't even own a dvb we
have a Vimeo page where you can actually
rent the videos for a real reasonable
cost okay what do they cost
'if they range but you know usually
about $4.99 $4.99 or $2.99 yeah okay so
that's that's cheap considering right
that's like that's like Redbox cheap
back to home box but you can get them
freddy cheap and it helps out our
ministry as well and we want to tell you
about another company where we actually
get a lot of stock media from it's
called video mission dot-com pictures
and video clips on there so if you are
like a youtuber making YouTube videos
and you need some high-class
video 4k cinematic reenactments of Bible
topics check these guys out video
mission com all right guys let's get
into this all right
so I want to give you some statistics
here the average person is going to
spend about forty three days on hold
with automated customer service into
your life I was doing that yesterday
right isn't that not just frustrating
but disliking and you know they play
this like super
just like steaming on the other end
right so uh you know I called Apple the
other day I don't remember what about
but you can actually choose your music
now yeah it's like you want classical
you want easy-listening you're really
upset but in a lifetime people are gonna
spend about forty three days on hold
human beings will also spend
approximately about six months of their
lives waiting in line for things Michele
you used a funny word for waiting in
line today what was that queue queue up
in the queue right so that's a lot of
time that people are gonna spend just
stand around wasting time and if you
notice what do people usually do with
their time when they're sitting around
staring at oh now they're on their
phones right everybody's on their phones
okay just driving in your car any of you
guys got a long commute yep
I Drive an hour both ways hour to work
man this man is dedicated to come to our
echo music that's a lot of time spin in
your car but what do you do in your car
watch a lot of YouTube I mean I listen I
find a good topic whether it's a sermon
or a show like this and I press play and
I put it in a place where I don't look
at it yeah right my - you know I used to
commute when I lived in Los Angeles for
a long time and I would listen to the
Bible and it was amazing just commuting
I mean I covered like so much of the
Bible just tons and tons of time to
spend in the car you know so you can
either talk to your friends or you can
gain something that would be profitable
so good good job I've done the Bible
also Keith gave me a book on tape of a
guy's testimony that I've been listening
to so so I was gonna say though just to
kind of play the other side on this if
you spend six months waiting in line and
that time is wasted and you were on your
phone doing something productive it's
really not and that's one thing that we
really want to highlight in here is what
are you doing with your time so that's
an excellent point
playing bejeweled and Lenore yeah that's
right you know time is interesting if
you guys ever looked into the theory of
relativity by Albert Einstein a little
bit yeah okay so time is it constant
he didn't think so he didn't think so
you're right
did you know that the time according to
his theories at your head is different
than the time at your feet did you not
know I can't comprehend that so here's
how they actually studied this they took
two clocks that were exactly the same
and they sent one up in the air and flew
it around and then they sent one on the
bottom and they studied the difference
in the time and there was a difference
in the time okay every year yes so that
that was basically his beginning stages
of him going whoa like what's the deal
with this thing called time it's
actually like it can be warped and it
can be changed and they actually had you
know he had a lot of very strange
theories of basically if you were like
sitting there looking at the Big Ben
clock right and you were backing away
from the clock if you could back away
from the clock at the speed of light the
clock would stop yeah trip out on that
it's like what but anyway it's very
interesting when you look at time time
is different for a lot of us and Keith
or Mikey now that we're a little bit
older than you two in the in the room
here do you guys feel like time is
speeding up that is right
why why why do you think it does that
the the best explanation I've ever heard
is the older you get that slice that
you're living is a smaller portion of
your life comparatively so for example
if you're four years old you know a year
is like it's a hits like now 20% of your
life yeah right
whereas if you're 90 a year is 119th of
your life right so it doesn't seem like
it's long it's going faster that's nice
Billy nation I've heard so that's
actually a pretty close explanation to
what these researchers found out it's
it's it's got a little bit different of
a variation of that here's what the
researchers wanted to test is
is is there actually a physiological
thing that's happening inside of our
brains that is basically making us
perceive time differently than someone
that is younger and that's kind of what
they were studying so when they really
looked at this they really looked at how
the brain processes images now when you
are in a new environment and something
is really exciting and and all of a
sudden you're like just taking it in
what your brain is doing is going like
focusing on all the image and then it's
like recording all this image when
you've been to some familiar place a lot
your brain doesn't need all that
information so it actually doesn't sit
there and analyze it like you would and
so what's happening is in someone that
is older their brain is actually like
for lack of a better term their
equipment is sort of breaking down and
so they their brain is not working in
the same capacity that someone who is
young that is analyzing that time and so
that analyzation actually appears that
it's a much longer period of time even
though the same time clock has gone by
so this is kind of what's interesting
this is what this article says quartz of
course they make watches this is what
they said in this article time is
happening in the mind's eye and it's
related to the number of mental images
that the brain encounters and organizes
the state and the state of our brains as
we age when we get older the rate at
which changes in the mental images are
perceived decreases because several
transforming physical features including
vision brain complexity and later in
life degradation of the pathways that
transmit the information and the shift
in image processing leads to the sense
of time speeding up so you know a shirt
that just completely went over my head
so you're just not processing the
information in the same way your your
brain is processing information faster
than my brain well that's that sounds a
bit complicated I just thought it was
responsibility you guys have kids and
all these things and you're just trying
to pack so much into your time whereas
we go home and we have more choice as to
what we spend our time doing there's got
to be an age where that where that you
know there's a crossover on that there
shoulde because otherwise you know
you're saying a newborn has the fastest
working brain and then it just goes
downhill from there and it would make
sense that there's a point of
degradation but up until that point it
sounds like yeah your brain is not
analyzing those images but it should
certainly be recalling them and not
spending the time and analyzation right
so the the article when you read the
whole thing actually talks about the
elderly driving why is someone who's
been on the planet for 80 years have a
harder time than a 20 year old that gets
in the car and it's because the 20 year
old like I can kind of equate this when
I played sports when I used to play
basketball and I was kind of in my prime
of it I could actually see where
everyone was and it was like my brain
was analyzing like okay this person is
gonna run here this person and it's
happening at a split second of a thing I
get out there and I try to play
basketball now and I'm just like like
time is not the same as what I remember
it to be in my earlier years so anyway
that's that's kind of it they have a lot
of graphs and stuff that they showed in
this article which was which was kind of
interesting how when you're younger you
perceive a lot more of these images when
you're older you perceive less or you
really like analyze them less okay so it
happens whether you're in a new
environment or not so the two of us
could be in a brand new environment
we've never seen it and we would respond
differently just because of age yes I
mean like he's like it said the factors
are also due to the equipment and so the
mental factors the aging process all
that kind of stuff so stops working
slower but yes it's there not looking at
those images in the same way that you
would be did it say at what point it
starts working slower or is it just like
kind of relevant because it's different
for different people
yeah as you get older I mean I've met
some 80 year olds that are sharp as a
tack yeah you know spit off a joke like
he was 20 years old so here's some more
interesting facts about time there was a
man that stood in line for a living have
you met these people or ever seen them
you you're from New York yeah people get
paid
the new iPhone is coming out and the
line is like three blocks down yes so
this is this is actually true in New
York okay yeah there there was people
that were paid to stand in line and
somebody waited ten days where the
iPhones camped out with their tents and
all that people bringing them food like
crying jeez I just wonder like honestly
what what do you need that phone for
that bad because someone's paying me I'm
not asking questions but isn't that an
interesting thing that
why would somebody pay for someone to do
that hmm because they think their time
is more valuable spent in other places
I'm gonna stand in line for ten days
like it's the dude using the bathroom
the curb or what I mean yeah I'm sure
they have to leave right I don't know
but basically they were paid about 300
bucks
to hold a spot for it for for Apple I
mean I don't know if that's $300 per day
or what I imagine total for ten days
yeah yeah in New Zealand when people
were waiting for the iPhone there were
actually allowed to have a little robot
or something that would hold their phone
and as long as they were connected to
FaceTime they could remain in the line
yeah so so whatever if I had to be like
there and your FaceTime had to see at
what point somebody's gonna pick up that
robot anyway the value of time so here's
an interesting thing how much time do
you think we actually spend on our
phones
so what birthday or yeah yeah give me a
guess this for is this like talking on
the phone or just doing everything on
the phone yeah playing with your phone
talking there phone could be all of the
above
half of your waking hours I don't think
okay so they spend about 23 days a year
24 hours 23 days a year so if you are
considering that you actually only slept
you know for eight hours out of the day
or whatever like this this is really
like closer to 40 or 50 days out of the
year you're gonna use how many days are
in a year so divide that that's
one-sixth roughly oh yeah right okay
mathematicians in the room one-sixth of
your day so yeah if you're awake for 10
hours out of the day how many hours is
that so you're roughly gonna spend 1/6
of the day at playing with your phone
now that translates to about 90 minutes
a day okay so 90 minutes a day is kind
of like what people actually are
spending now if you kept that pace up
that's 9 years of the average person's
life assuming that you sleep yes Yeah
right
almost and what is that 1/10 of your
life you know I feel like people spend
more time than that really a bit yeah I
don't think that's not bad yeah if
you're just communicating with people
using the work that we do what if you
were reading the Bible on your phone
what if you were doing productive things
how would I find that's nice but that
that would actually be an incredible
amount of time that you would accumulate
yeah learning something positive so
that's just something to keep in mind
what people are doing with their with
their time market watch is is is
actually stating that most people spend
a majority of their waking hours on
their devices now I don't know how they
came to this conclusion and timex that
was who did this study before it came to
a little bit different of a conclusion
but I think what these guys are taking
into account is people working in front
of computers now I work in front of a
computer as well you guys all do too so
that's what nine hours we're spending in
front of like you know something so
majority of our day is literally spent
in front of these screens now that's
just that's just a lot of screen
time and so it's pretty easy to be
distracted you know like when you sit
down
you go to answer an email and all of a
sudden before you know it you're
watching YouTube yeah that happens it
happens actually a lot we've shown this
graph before but I wanted to show this
to our viewers literally just to keep
this before their minds how much time
people are actually spending doing these
various different activities out of the
day people sleep about eight eight and a
half hours out of the day they work
about 5.75 hours out of the day and then
the blue little graph here the blue part
of the of the pie is what people spend
in leisure time leisure sports all that
there's a little pink sliver right in
there that basically is how much time
people spend in civil or religious
activities so reading your Bible
anything like that is 0.21 hours out of
the day that's the that's the reality of
what people are doing at a time most
people are not spending much time in
religious activities at all I wonder I
wish there was like a statistic of this
in 40s or something you know there's
still yeah maybe they didn't have phones
but they still had go to the show or
whatever would religious activities
still be so small or would it be more of
a yeah wider area you'd be interesting
to see if we had some sort of data on
the 1800s I mean those people knew their
Bibles yeah you read those stories of
the Great Awakening and it's like they
were like oh yeah this verse this verse
mom you know we're like hold on I'll
look that up yeah I'll do the lab yeah
that would be very interesting but this
is how much time people are actually
spending in religious activities here's
something that I found that was kind of
interesting to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics so this is what people do
with their time this is obviously taken
from the United States Department of
Labor so what everybody's doing with
their time total care and helping for
the household you can see part of this
graph they're spending a fair amount of
time caring for the children and stuff
physical care for children you can see
the graph go down I want you to notice
how it says reading to household
children
this is like point zero Lisa melon thing
if the smallest thing on there what
people are doing with their time they
are not reading to their kids and I mean
that is alarming because it's like you
know as a family we have family worship
every single night and we read books and
we read stories to our kids and I know
you guys do with that the same as well
with your kids you know you think about
how valuable that is the average United
States child is not read to by their
parents and so you know it's less than
let's see if that's one hour it's less
than five minutes reading to the
children and for you girls when you guys
have children I'm telling you the best
thing you could do for your children is
to read to them I mean it's just an
amazing thing when they all of a sudden
just you see them soak up a desire for
learning I think yours daughter Keith is
like a total bookworm right yeah I mean
they can't buy books fast enough for her
daughter she's just like no yeah it's
awesome so here's why I bring this up
Deuteronomy six six through nine says
this and these words which I command
thee this day shall be in thy heart and
thou shalt teach them diligently unto
thy children and thou shalt talk of them
when thou sittest down in thy house and
when thou walkest by the way and when
thou liest down and when thou rises up
and thou shalt bind them for a sign upon
my hand and and shall be frontlets
between thy eyes and thou shalt write
them upon the posts of the house and on
thy gates well the reason why God gave
this inspiration to Moses to teach the
children of Israel you need to teach the
children the ways of God part of doing
that is sitting down and reading to them
spending time with them and spending
time teaching them right that's that's
that's what Moses was really hammering
away in it and what's interesting is
when I read the Bible it's like it's no
different for us today we can see we
have this same struggle as what those
children of Israel did because
but this if you read a little bit later
right you remember Joshua judges to 10
through 11 says and also all that
generation that were gathered unto their
fathers there arose another generation
after them which knew not the Lord nor
yet the works which he had done for
Israel and the children of Israel did
evil in the sight of the Lord and served
Balaam in one generation one generation
by the parents not reading to the child
and spending time to teach the children
those important religious principles one
generation they walked away from God and
I I've seen this personally in my family
I have family members in my family that
did not teach their children about the
ways of God and now they're literally
like you know what what did I do what
can I do now
how can I get them back and so it's very
important not only do we need to spend
time with God but we need to also spend
that time teaching and educating our
children and that's why it says in
Deuteronomy 6:5 thou shalt love the Lord
thy God with all thy heart with all they
sold with all they might teach your
children those concepts as well it's
it's scary that the times we're living
in now and how it seems like parents are
afraid to teach their children you know
that the word teach has now been
replaced with impose or they don't want
to offend anyone or they want that they
don't want their child to feel either
left out of things so go try whatever
you want to make your own decisions it's
like well are you raising your child
then you know how do you know how do you
raise a child without teaching them
morals and your beliefs and all these
things that's right that's right
you know instead we're giving devices to
our kids we're giving them the phones
we're giving them well that's a good
point if you don't teach them the world
will tell whether they come in contact
all right so all the movies I mean you
just think about like let's just say
your kid watches a movie or two a week
right and you did no reading to them you
you you've now just educated them in the
ways of Hollywood yeah exact world
whereas you missed out on an opportunity
to teach them these divine principles
and I feel like not teaching is teaching
in itself
in a strange way because by youths
remaining silent that opens the door to
the opposite and who knows where the
child will end up without any guidance
or formal training right it's a good
point so because of our use of time if
you look at Christians specifically it's
not really a surprise that I think this
was put out by Barna Group when they
pulled Christians they said you know
what do you what are you most confident
what do you least confident in they said
we're best at maintaining healthy
relationships as Christians we think we
do that better than anything the thing
that they listed were statistically was
Bible knowledge yes
Christians and so I'm thinking something
wrong with that picture because how can
you say that you're best at maintaining
relationships if your relationship with
God which is created by you know
spending time in his word is least you
have the least confidence your Bible
knowledge is is low how could you expect
to get any of your relationships really
right and healthy yeah yeah when you're
looking at where's your priority do you
want to maintain as many friendships as
you can with whoever you can and kind of
suppress what you believe or is God the
person that you're really trying to
maintain a relationship with and if
that's the case unfortunately it happens
naturally you will lose some some
earthly friendships rights with which
one do you see more important seek first
the kingdom of God and His righteousness
and all these things shall be added unto
you it's like whatever the desires are
of your heart when you put God as the
primary focus he will he will give you
the things that really give you those
pieces of happiness and the peace and
the joy and the things that that are in
life proverbs 8:17 says this I love them
that love me and those that seek me
early shall find me I think this is cool
because there there are so many people
that are searching for all kinds of
things in life to make them happy and
and it's really neat like God is is even
though he's far away we have not seen
him and he promises us literally if you
seek me you will find me that is a
promise that whatever you're struggling
with if you need answers and you are
like God show
yourself right that's what this Bible
verse says he will show up and he will
say you you you will meet me what do you
think the latter part of that verse is
alluding to why does it specifically say
early I believe that like anything else
have you studied the topic of food it's
very interesting what you put in your
stomach
first actually dictates what you're
gonna eat the rest of the day did you
know that if you actually have the wrong
type of like like crackers and things
like this in the morning
you're gonna chase that cracker all day
long I just think so if you start out
your day with a relationship with God
like lovingly opening your heart to him
I guarantee you it's like all of a
sudden it sets the stage for everything
else that's right like the world
understands this concept as well you
have a ward ceremony right it's very
important to them who comes out first
and sets the stage for the night right
we have we have that all the time I mean
there's they're always talking about
this in different avenues of you know
public speaking or whatever like this
it's like I think that when you start
your day that will set the stage for how
the events are gonna roll out in your
day like since think about this Adam and
Eve being created in the Garden of Eden
right I I just I love kind of just like
mentally thinking about this experience
God came down often in the cool of the
day to hang out with him you know yeah
right
he left them too the whole day you guys
do what you want right he comes down at
the end of the day you know what you
what you see would you like what you do
right he just wanted to hang out with
them and be with him and then he
reserves this whole day he was Irv's the
Sabbath he says for one day I'm all
yours I got a lot of stuff in the
universe but I'm gonna come and hang out
with you guys and and I want you guys to
hang out with me we're just gonna spend
the whole day together right when you
kind of view our time like that then it
really makes sense God God is so patient
with us he gives us six days to do
whatever it is that we want but one day
he says I want to spend time with you
that's all I want to spend time with you
and if we begin to look at our time with
it like that then we would be like you
know not so let's can't do this and I
can't do that a weekend and blah blah
because it's the Sabbath you know it'd
be really becomes this other day where
it's just like no this is about a
relationship in a relationship with God
it's very interesting when you look at
the story or the parable that Jesus told
in Matthew 22 1 through 14 we won't read
the whole thing just for the sake of
time but this is the story where a
wedding was prepared and you know the
king sent out his servants and said you
know you know it's all prepared like
please come to the wedding and Keith do
you remember what what what happened
well some people it seemed like they
wanted to come but they had some other
things to do and so they said you know
that's great but they made some excuses
you don't have to attend to my business
or my farm and so I'm gonna take a rain
check
yeah so isn't it interesting that in
this very important time everybody loves
to go to a wedding right I mean it's fun
there's there's food everybody's in a
good mood yet there's people who have so
filled their time they did not have time
for this event
mm-hmm and that's that's that I think is
shocking and you know in this verse it
even uses the word remnant right knows
that we're left right I kind of consider
the Christians at the end of the world
here they're remnant and they were the
ones that were lately like now I've got
I've got other things to do I think we
need to be careful that we don't just
get so busy in life that we're literally
like only spending time with God when
it's convenient you know I mean I also
believe that time is it is it is a
talent it is yeah you guys remember the
story of talents mm-hmm right the
parable so everybody's given a talent
right and basically God is is requiring
at the end of his time when he comes
back and he says what did you do with
this talent that I gave to you right I
believe that every single one of
is going to have to answer to God with
the use of our time everyone has given
an equal almost an equal allotment of
time like you know we may not have the
same skills we know I have the same
public speaking abilities or whatever we
vary in all of those those skill sets
but all of us have this very consistent
thing of time and you know did you use
your time wisely you know it's also
interesting a lot of people like to
focus on the talents that were given but
there were also talents that were
required and if we all have the talent
of time some people are born with the
natural gift of being good at music if
they sit down at a piano and within a
year they're you know masters at this
instrument some people who may take
longer but they could still acquire it
and use it for God so yes everyone has
time and that's the beautiful thing
about it is that although we may not be
born with ten different talents we can
acquire ten different talents based off
of traits that we learn and develop
within ourselves and I think that's
really encouraging that we're not just
left with nothing time is actually the
greatest talent of them all that's right
that's right the Bible has a lot to say
about time but I really am fascinated by
the idea that everybody has this
specific different talent I mean
literally like I've worked in enough
work environments and and I love it like
I love working with you guys you guys
each bring something unique to the table
everybody has this skill and we put all
of our of our talents together we can
make something beautiful with that you
know and it's just really neat I think
if everybody was the same there would be
a lot more head-butting and and I think
you know I've learned to appreciate the
variety of what everybody brings to the
table but this whole stewardship of time
I believe is is the reason why we wanted
to do this led in the first place was
just a really to put before people
listen time is an important thing that
we all need to be aware of where we are
in the wake of time I mean there is
there are some awesome prophecy channels
out there and prophecy is is an amazing
thing I mean we've got you know
Bible prophecy made clear school for
prophets I mean if you guys haven't
checked these guys out we'll put some
links in the description below
check them out look into the time
prophecies of the Bible I mean it's a
powerful way to literally walk away from
this going this is impossible for
somebody to guess what just happened
there's there has to be a God and he has
to have this whole thing mapped out only
God can see into the future
no no Satan cannot see into the future
and so you know take a look at where we
are in the wake of time pull your head
out of the the media Sam boxes and wood
and look around because I believe that
Jesus is coming soon I really believe
that and we need to be aware of the time
and the day that we live in it reminds
me of Matthew 25 where Jesus separates
these two groups of people the sheep and
and and the goats you know and I think
it's I'd have to look I'm not coming up
off the top of my head but it could be
in that same chapter where where he's
talking to people and he's saying you
know you know you did this and you did
this and you did this or you didn't do
this and you didn't do this and you
didn't do this you know like you didn't
visit me in prison and you didn't give
me you know food when I was hungry and
you do this all those things have a time
element and those people who were
faithful to God they they spent their
time doing these things you know like
feeding people or clothing them or what
have you and the and he says you know
when you've done it to those people you
did it to me
and the other people were like well they
didn't they didn't they didn't have a
second thought about it because they
were just you know like in tune with
serving Christ and the other view like
but but we never saw you you know and so
they spent their time doing other things
you know it seems like in in every in
maybe not everything but the majority of
things you read in the Bible is when it
comes to parables are all stories that
Jesus tells there's a time aspect like
even the Good Samaritan he stopped he
took the time to do something or
somebody
and yeah did he have other things to do
he did but he still stopped and took the
time to take care of somebody just like
God comes down off of his throne
you know then we have the incarnation
what does he do he takes his time away
from heaven and he dedicates that time
to saving an entire race of people and
now what is he doing interceding for
people spending his time so this is a
huge you know huge topic and I think God
is is interested in how we spend our
time and if we were to ask ourselves
that question you know does God care
what I do with my time yeah and I think
we answer that honestly yes he does and
we need to come in and come to him and
ask God what do you want me to do with
my time one of the coolest stories I
think in the Bible is the story of
Hezekiah King Hezekiah and when he got
sick and all of a sudden it was like
he's on his deathbed and he's crying out
to God and God sends a prophet to him
and says God heard you cry and he's
gonna give you a little bit more time he
gave him 15 more years to live right
Brad I mean can you imagine like
literally a prophet coming into you
going you're on your deathbed you got 15
years clock's ticking
yeah what would you do with your time at
that point right but look at what King
Hezekiah did all of a sudden he gets you
know going and things are fine and he
kind of forgets about God and it's like
you know he asked for a sign I forgot to
mention this part he asked for a sign
that this would be true that he would
have 15 more years and and so the
Prophet said we'll do you want the Sun
to go forwards or backwards they love
it's not really a big deal to make it go
forward make it go backwards cuz
nobody's ever seen it go backwards right
and so all of a sudden the Sun goes
backwards I think three hours if I'm if
I'm right right or something like this
and so all of a sudden guess who's gonna
show up wondering who had the power to
turn the Sun back who who do you think
showed up yeah no no a Gyptian king of
Babylon yeah the very Sun worshiping
people and it's all of a sudden their
God that's been consistently going
around the world
for whatever however many centuries and
all of a sudden it goes backwards and
they're like oh whoa what just happened
so then they want to seek out who did
this and the word gets back to Hezekiah
and they come and visit him and what
does he do yeah I got I got a Tesla out
there in the in the in the garage you
want to see this thing what do you want
I want to see my chariot hmm
says nothing about God and so do you
know what those Babylonians did they
went back to Babylon and they said this
guy is crazy rich and that word actually
got passed down from Kings and when the
king that that actually went to go take
Daniel and Shadrach Meshach and Abednego
it was literally because of Hezekiah has
sinned and they went let's go rob these
people Wow and when Daniel do you think
of Daniel Daniel was you know being
tested in his in his dedication to God
you know they they try to get Darius to
sign this decree that you know he would
spend your time if you will doing other
things but it spend it focusing on
Darius you know for 30 days and Daniel
said no my time for God is my time for
God and I'm not gonna change that for
anybody and when he did that God was
faithful to him and preserved his life
so time is a huge you know huge topic so
true so I'll read to you this article
from Forbes magazine which itself is
very interesting how do the very wealthy
choose to spend their time good take a
guess traveling do you think that there
is a big difference with the amount of
leisure time that someone who's uber
wealthy and someone who's not over
wealthy do you think there's a big
difference because yes sure yeah sure
people are rich they're just bored man
they start coming all kinds of crazy
stuff to do okay wait so you think that
rich people actually it ends more wasted
time oh no I wouldn't say rich person
wasted time I would say maybe they spend
more time on vacation but they probably
work as harder harder than other people
okay we're like there's a difference
between working hard and
and working smart or like the time you
spend working suddenly very efficient
right very efficient so they're able to
work maybe the same amount or even less
and do more than the average person
who's doing the same amount of time so
this study came out of Harvard and a few
other really big schools that I can't
even pronounce where they never even are
and they studied thousands of people
that were quoting quotes really rich and
some people that were like not so rich
and the interesting thing they found out
listen to this there is however some key
differences between the two for one
although millionaires and non
millionaires enjoyed approximately the
same amount of leisure time millionaires
engaged in more active leisure
activities such as praying socializing
exercise hobbies and volunteering while
non millionaires engaged in more passive
leisure such as watching TV mapping
resting or doing nothing so that's
that's interesting right so it wasn't
necessarily that both wasted like this
crazy amount of time it was just like
well what did they do with their leisure
time rich people who are over uber
millionaires I didn't really read
anything that was like they were playing
gta5 you know for five hours out of the
day right they were literally being
productive and I thought this was
interesting that they threw in their
praying and volunteering right yeah
think about the talent of time he was
kind of frustrating God's promises apply
to whoever followed them because most of
his promises are conditional you know
when you think of tithe prayer and all
these things do this you get this result
doesn't matter you know who you believe
in or you know these other things once
you do X hare is your your reward
so yeah that's it's kind of forgotten is
so he is so honoring yeah he promise to
you that's why I really believe the
Jewish nation
they've always in throughout history
have made money there's some of the both
wealthy people on the world right and
the reason why is God promised those
people they would be blessed and they
are blessed they're blessed in business
I've heard business people say you you
even want to get into business deals
with a Jew because he will have the
upper hand every day and God won't go
back on that doesn't matter how what if
they they literally killed God mm-hmm
and yet he's like nope I'm still gonna
honor what I told you I was had anything
for you and so when we adhere to the
principles that God set up being others
focus spending time with God
volunteering our time to just ease the
suffering of someone else he blesses
that I'm reading a book right now
because I like sociological studies and
it's talking about Asian people Michelle
and it's kind of alluding to the fact
it's like you know we look at a lot of
Asians and say man they're just so
successful like how do they have the
upper hand in business and jobs and all
this and a lot of it comes from their
history of how they've operated for
hundreds if not thousands of years prior
they have this almost ingrained work
ethic if you will and they're so the
book I'm reading is talking about how
for example in China you have these rice
paddies right and they don't or haven't
for a long time used a lot of heavy-duty
equipment it's a lot of manual labor and
yeah hand putting it in the ground it's
hard hard work and these people can
sometimes get two harvests in a season
Wow you know if they do it right you
know if they make sure their paddy is
level because you have a layer of clay
on the bottom so that you can hold the
water and then you have a layer of soil
on top of that and it's just like
they've got different kinds of rice they
know how to plant when to plant
what rice to plant because it might be a
dry season so this plant acts better in
a dry season it means I've got it all
figured out right now you think about
that as it carries forward if that's if
that's your legacy you know and that's
your your family heritage and history
and you've grown up doing it these
people sometimes have worked 3,000 hours
in a year
you know so when it comes to you move on
to other things like the corporate world
there's they're used to working and
working hard and so it's like why are
they successful well they're used to
working and working hard you know that's
why in Tokyo they have a little box that
they sleep in about this much they stay
for an hour and then they go back to
work
comparatively during the same years that
these you know they were looking at
studies of how they cultivated rice
fields
you'd have Europeans hardly working at
all in fact they would because things
were bad or hard they would like start
starving themselves it's like well you
know I can't seem to make it for the
food instead of getting out there and
like working harder than just like well
I'm just gonna go into you know economic
mode and eat less and it's just kind of
interesting
I like Spain's method you know like just
take time off and nap middle of the day
I wanted to put this slide in here just
the knowledge of truth is altogether too
precious to be hoarded up bound about
hitting the earth even one talent
entrusted by the master is to be
faithfully employed mm-hmm so often we
have this knowledge especially if you're
a Christian and you've grown up with
this information there's a whole world
out there that knows nothing about the
Bible and you know if we just spend a
little bit of time how do I evangelize
how do I reach out how do I share my
faith even if you're not the one that
can say it you know what a brilliant way
that you can do watch videos and then
email that video to somebody you know to
mean send somebody a link and say hey I
watch this really cool YouTube channel
called LED live you guys should check
that out yeah yeah i mean it's off the
chain right so that's that's a way where
if you can't even say it you can use
that time to to write up a quick email
to your friends family and share that
with people you know sentiment book like
what Mikey does you know he's always
sending books to people I think that's
just a beautiful way I want to share
with you there is an interesting
that was written by a nurse that she was
a nurse that worked with dying patients
and so when they were always constantly
dying she would obviously talk with them
and and you know being a hospice nurse
she would you know ask them if there's
anything that they regret in life and
she noticed that there was the same
things coming up over and over again
everybody that was dying literally was
like saying the same things I regret
this this this and this and so she
decided to write a book and I want to
share with you some of the things that
that people regret most to die when they
die
number one regret that came up over and
over and over again was I wished that I
had the courage to live a life that was
true to myself and not a life that
others expected of me that's dude it's
deep right because the world tries to
push on us some sort of life that we
need to live and conform us into this
box that we need to have that kind of
clothing and that kind of car and that
kind of lifestyle or whatever like this
right and that's the picture that our
society is putting out there and people
regret that demos well can I say it's
true for also the Christian that they
were trying to live for others or live
from this book I'm trying to conform
enough themselves to that instead of
developing a relationship with Christ
and then living it living out their life
truly for him and not for others having
a more enjoyable Christian experience
instead of a miserable one I would agree
number two wish that people had when
they died as I wish I hadn't worked so
hard they said I think it was 75% of all
the males had this one thing to say I
actually recently ran into a guy that
was in the real estate and he when I was
talking with him I was kind of
interested in real estate and so I was
like you know so you you know you have
how many houses in this area and he said
I had a hundred and something houses in
Chattanooga like are you are you just
like like crazy rich he's like look I
had no life my kids grew up around me
and all I was doing was literally
running around and doing all this and he
goes now I'm old I can't spend the money
and I've gotten gobs of it and what did
I do
I wasted my life so think about that
though number two wish that every
dying person has pretty much is I wish I
wouldn't have died or wish it wouldn't
have worked so hard number three I wish
I would have that had the courage to
express my feelings dude yeah yeah
feeling it already right tell someone
that you love them tell them that you
appreciate them
I can't even begin to tell you like when
you begin to praise God what it does to
your your thinking about God get in that
habit of telling God God you are so
awesome man you you you just take care
of me like like amazingly and I don't
deserve any of this and you just
verbalize that constantly to God it will
change the way that you view God that
was my entire car right here this
morning man yeah
after the things they did for me
yesterday you know often I get in the
car and like I said I'd try to find some
thing to watch or something I was like
no I'm gonna praise God for what he's
been doing in my life you know the Train
that's right here's number four I wish
that it would have stayed in touch with
my friends you know we all go through
life we kind of get busy we get new
friends I actually have a friend of mine
right now that I'm praying for and I'm
praying for her hard and I say God give
me this friend give me this friend he's
not converted I know he's not converted
but he has a heart of gold give me this
friend and that takes time for you to
stay in touch you don't I mean you've
got to communicate you've got to be in a
relationship number five I wish I would
have let myself be happier that was the
number five wish to let themselves be
happy right wow that's nice some people
feel either guilty or whatever Romans
13:11 through 12 says this and that
knowing the time that is now high time
to wake out of sleep for now is our
salvation nearer than when we believed
the night is far spent the day is at
hand let is therefore cast off the works
of darkness and let us put on the armor
of light I believe that if we were to
pick our heads out of the sand and look
at the time where we live in today we
would realize real fast time is so short
the time that we have on this planet is
so short and if you just learn to be
wise with your time
spend it getting a knowledge of God
spend it getting the knowledge of how to
share your knowledge with other people I
guarantee you you will be so excited
when you get to heaven and somebody
walks up to you in heaven and says you
know what my whole family is here
because of something that you said to me
mmm that I think will be worth more than
anything else and when you get to heaven
did you know that 57 percent of all
people surveyed this is according to a
Timex survey say they don't need an
alarm clock oh that's nice yeah yes IKEA
I hate alarm clock and I Britt I rarely
actually put them up and it drives my
wife nuts because she's like why don't
you why don't you set an alarm you know
like I'll wake up I know I'll wake up
you know and I generally do it's very
rare that I'll actually sleep in after
admit it is pretty cool there was a time
where I was better and more scheduled
with when I went to bed and when I woke
up and yeah I would actually wake up
before my alarm clock just a few minutes
before and it's it's pretty cool but I
can't stand being woken up abruptly I
think that's my main good I do not like
like like I remember one of those Zen
ones that kind of yes a piece that is
really soft and it needs to whisper
things in my ear I purposely picked the
most annoying ringtone yeah the only way
I can do it is to have an alarm set
every five minutes for an entire hour
have you slept through inaudible that
was the main high school everything
blaring stepmother I think that's like
multiple like six seven put a ring at
the same time all the time yeah you keep
shutting up and it's like after the 71
we throw that do this huh I want to
share with you this verse in Ephesians
5:8 through 21 for you are sometimes in
darkness but year now light in the Lord
walk as children of the light for the
fruit of the Spirit is in all goodness
and righteousness and truth proving what
is the acceptable unto the Lord and have
no fellowship with the unfruitful works
of darkness but rather reprove them or
expose them for it is a shame to even
speak of the things that which
those are for it is a shame even to
speak of those things which are done of
them in secret but all things that are
reproved are made manifest by the light
for what for whatsoever doth make
manifest is light wherefore he saith
awake thou that sleepest and arise from
the dead and Christ shall give thee
lights see then that they that ye walk
circumspectly not as fools but as the
wise redeeming the time because the days
are evil redeeming the time that's right
so don't walk as children in darkness
there's a lot of light the Bible has a
lot of positive information on how to
live a better life I believe that's what
it's really there for it's there to
improve the quality of life and not keep
you in darkness and we arms in Proverbs
are some good ones right yeah you know
we're running out of time so spend it
wisely that's what I wanted to say we
hope you guys enjoyed this led live and
thank you so much for spending time with
us you know we found we counted such an
honor to be able to share information
what we're excited about talk about some
of these life issues so you know if you
want to share our channel with someone
else get on Facebook write a little post
you know send us your stories if if this
ministry has been really impactful in
your life or your walk
we want to hear about it it not only
gives our team encouragement but it also
gives other people encouragement as well
to know that God can change and
transform your life so we hope that what
you gain out of this led is you need to
be able to spend some good quality time
with God to build a proper relationship
with him so don't waste time on all of
this media junk in the world that our
channel has analyzed for the last 10
years really pick up the source of truth
the Word of God get to know the God of
the Bible and spend some time with him
you will not be sorry we thank you guys
so much for tuning in and don't forget
to Like and subscribe if you haven't
god bless
[Music]